najat belhassen bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors pour
commencer votre réaction la fermeture
des écoles elle était inéluctable selon
vous non elle n'était pas inéluctable
dans le sens où cela fait un nom que le
virus circule en france et il cela fait
un an que l'on discute de la question
des écoles et des établissements
scolaires
et aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu'en
fait on n'avait pas du tout anticipé
cette fermeture et on n'a pas mis les
moyens si vous voulez pour que les
moyens nécessaires je parle humains et
matériels pour que les établissements
scolaires restent reste ouvert et essai
et c'est bien là le noeud du problème en
fait sur le premier confinement lorsque
les établissements scolaires ont fermé
les parents l'ont acceptée parce qu'en
effet le c'était une nouveauté le virus
était était arrivé en france nous étions
tous un peu sous le choc et la solde la
solidarité pardon à jouer plein pot
aujourd'hui un an après les parents ne
comprennent plus que l'on puisse encore
aujourd'hui et revenir un peu si vous
voulez sur sur tout ce qui a été fait et
10 cette année et fermer les
établissements scolaires alors que il y
avait depuis depuis des mois en fait des
signes d'alerté des sonnettes d'alarmé
qui avaient été tirées notamment nous en
tant que fédération de parents nous
avions fait des propositions pour
justement limiter par exemple le
brassage des élèves dans les
établissements scolaires et il est bien
là le noeud du problème c'est que c'est
de savoir s est enfin de savoir non
puisque maintenant c'est à s'est avouée
par le l'exécutif
le virus circule bien dans les
établissements dans les établissements
scolaires pardon alors que ce n'était
pas le cas au début et donc ça c'est une
c'est un vrai souci en fait de
compréhension si vous voulez par rapport
par rapport à cette fermeture
aujourd'hui pour une exécution disait
que ce n'était pas le cas au début en
tout cas en tout cas c'est un véritable
casse-tête pour les parents que vous
représentez à une semaine
justement cccc de mettre ses enfants à
l'école comment est ce que les parents
l'appréhendent est aussi le
bouleversement du calendrier pour les
vacances tout à fait alors aujourd'hui
si vous voulez bon déjà c'est toujours
un peu des annonces qui arrive à la
dernière minute
les parents n'ont pas le temps de se
préparer finalement donc ils essayent de
jouer un peu las de la débrouille en ce
en commençant très dense où il est soit
entre voisins soit avec les grands
parents soit voilà on a alors pour ceux
qui sont un télétravail comme pour ceux
qui travaillent sur ce site
parce que faut enfin il faut se rendre
compte que les parents aujourd'hui même
en télétravail avec des enfants en bas
âge c'est extrêmement compliqué donc
même pour s'assimiler là ils sont ils
sont un peu paniqués parce que ils ne
veulent pas revivre ce qu'ils ont vécu
au premier confinement ce qui a été
extrêmement durs pour eux et y compris
pour les enfants parce que
psychologiquement on oublie aussi que le
premier confinement a laissé des traces
que ce soit chez les enfants comme chez
les adultes
et aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression qu'on a
qu'on a oublié complètement cette partie
là et que finalement on revient un peu
en arrière alors vous vous souligné à
l'instant cette difficulté justement de
télé travailler avec des enfants à la
maison beaucoup de le parent le dise
vous avez pu le dire ça au gouvernement
tant que représentante de parents
d'élèves au niveau national vous avez eu
un dialogue avec des représentants du
gouvernement avant l'annoncé de la
fermeture des écoles
alors avec les représentants avec les
représentants du ministère nous avions
eu des réunions
si vous voulez par contre le ministre
était fréquemment fréquemment absent
donc le dialogue de le dialogue qui
aurait dû s'instaurer si vous voulez
pour préparer les parents et puis faire
des propositions essayer de trouver
d'autres solutions n'a pas eu lieu mais
n'a pas vraiment pas sûrs on a fait
plusieurs plusieurs propositions on a
fait cette proposition
pour éviter cette fermeture est
aujourd'hui on a vraiment l'impression
de ne pas être écoutés nous avions
proposé dès 2000 groupe nous avions
proposé des masques chirurgicaux offert
à tous les toutes les familles pour que
pour que les enfants puissent justement
porter des masques chirurgicaux à
l'école nous avions proposé des
lavements pour que
pour que les enfants puissent se laver
les mains et puis surtout nous avions
proposé que les enseignants se fassent
vacciner en première ligne ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui donc toutes ces
mesures si vous voulez alors je peux
détailler mais mais toutes ces mesures
on a l'impression qu'elles n'ont pas été
prises en compte et que la solution de
facilité
c'est quand même de fermer les écoles et
la question si vous voulez de la
continuité pédagogique
enfin on l'a testé sur les lycéens les
lycées ont été en demi jauge là pendant
un certain moment on le sait très bien
nous entendre par an ça ne fonctionne
pas alors ça ne fonctionne pas pour des
lycéens mais imaginez aussi chez pour
des tout petits
il va falloir vraiment que les parents
s'arment de patience
être enseignant c'est un métier on le
dit depuis le début
et aujourd'hui on va encore vivre
simuler ce qu'on a vécu au début et on
est vraiment à bout de souffle avec la
crise sanitaire plus l'état
psychologique des familles ça va être
très compliqué parmi les mesures
également qu'ils avaient été préconisées
pour éviter la fermeture de ces écoles
ce sont les tests annoncés en grande
pompe d'ailleurs la sortie des vacances
de février est ce que ça a été le cas
depuis les vacances de février est ce
que les élèves aient été testés
systématiquement avant d'aller à l'école
avec ces tests salivaires notamment
alors les tests salivaires avait lieu
ciblé dans les petites écoles donc dans
l'eau et maternelles élémentaires sur
les lycées les collèges c'était des
tests antigénique ce qui s'est passé si
vous voulez c'est que les tests n'ont
pas pu être généralisé et pour cause je
pense que c'était beaucoup trop tard en
fait nous deux à la fcpe depuis le
premier confinement on demande à ce que
les ans les élèves soient testés ça n'a
pas été fait dès le début donc on a
attendu encore une fois la dernière
ligne pour pouvoir le mettre en place
donc forcément il était déjà trop tard
le virus avait déjà commencé à circuler
dans les établissements scolaires et en
plus j'ai envie de vous dire les tests
il faut que ce soit fait de manière
régulière
sinon ça n'a plus de ça n'a plus de sens
en fait bien sûr et avant et surtout
avant d'entrer à l'école et contaminé 2
d'autres élèves c'est compliqué en tant
que parents justement cette peur on nous
l'a souvent racontée ici sur le plateau
d' rt france la peur des parents
justement de d'attraper le virus par par
les enfants comment est ce que quand
est-ce que c'est vécu
bah c'est forcément mal a mal vécu je
vous donne l'exemple
voilà moi moi je suis personnes à risque
quand le variant brutal quand le premier
call variant britannique a été déclaré
dans le collège de ma fille m'a bien sûr
on ce qu'on se pose beaucoup de
questions et en plus en tant que parent
si vous voulez c'est tellement anxiogène
que forcément les enfants le ressentent
aussi parce qu'on leur dit voilà il faut
respecter les gestes barrière faute
laver les mains faut porter le masque
sur le nez pour les tout petits
c'est très compliqué donc donc forcément
ça devient très anxiogène et pour nous
en fait c'est un peu ce que l'on
reproche à l'exécutif aujourd'hui c'est
de ne pas avoir anticipé tout ça parce
que aujourd'hui le moral des français
correspond tout à fait à celui de toutes
les familles
j'ai envie de vous dire et de toute la
jeunesse c'est qu'ils sont un peu à bout
de souffle et avoir joué le la longueur
sur enfin le temps n'a pas forcément
l'effet escompté on le voit bien
aujourd'hui et même peut-être faire les
plus de dégâts que si peut-être qu'on
avait été confiné un peu plus tôt
vous parliez d'anticipation vous en tant
que parent d'élève
on a trois semaines pour les pommes pour
les écoles et les primaires quatre
semaines sans présence à l'école
normalement pour les collèges et les
lycées
est-ce que dès maintenant il faut
anticiper prévoir cette rentrée et
comment à quoi faut-il penser
alors oui il faut anticiper cette
rentrée donc la première chose que l'on
demande de toute façon c'est d'avoir
vous savez le ministre de l'éducation a
rendu cette année 200 millions aux
finances au ministère des finances
aujourd'hui on demande au ministre de
remettre en fait ce
cet argent sur sur le budget de
l'éducation nationale pour équiper les
salles par exemple de détecteurs de co2
pour équiper les élèves de masques
chirurgicaux et les enseignants il faut
absolument que les enseignants soient
pour ceux qui le souhaitent vacciner
très rapidement et puis surtout à la
rentrée parce que les collèges et des
lycées vont sans doute être en 2012
comme ça a été le cas pour les lycées il
faut prévoir le fait que certains vont
passer des examens et donc dans quelques
cadres ils vont passer ses examens
et puis et surtout le plus gros problème
si les dons dans l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui c'est que quand on a une
classe de 30 élèves par classe par
classe oui et qu'une professeur est
absent dans l'école les élèves de
l'autre classes vont être dispatchés sur
les autres classes donc on se retrouve
avec des effectifs entre 35 et 40 par
classe donc le brassage il est et c'est
une catastrophe pour les pour les élèves
donc il faut diminuer le nombre d'élèves
par classe faire de 2000 groupe ouvrir
des tiers lieux pourquoi pas des centres
et certaines communes ont même ont même
proposé de mettre à disposition les
centres de loisirs même des salles des
gymnases enfin voilà et puis surtout il
faut recruter en masse
et comme on sait que l'éducation
nationale a un problème de recrutement
qu'on peut pas le faire du jour au
lendemain
pourquoi pas faire appel à des étudiants
pour pour encadrer justement les élèves
de l'épicerie et qui serait en demi
groupe et ça c'est tout à fait faisable
des del à leur tour en avril prochain
oui en les rémunérant c'est une bonne
idée merci beaucoup maj est belhassem
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france